oh thank god you're here we're just
about to go on there come on guys
that's it come on
tonight on 16 minutes we have with us a
superhero who has staged two travelers
who were kidnapped today we have with us
tiffany
eduardo and the superhero with the most
incredible name
sorry what was your name
wanda webb
underwear
so uh
wonderland we heard that she were
in
in the middle of your cape progression
you dashed off and ran off the rock
into thin air
now what was that about well
that's because one of the other
superheroes stole my cape
and i'm actually chasing after her and
trying to get it trying to get it back
and then
she
whipped away from right at the last
minute and i had to fly off the rock um
you know and i saved a few people who
were also coming to me
and
basically that's what happened
it was just you know by pure accident
and the loss of my mccabe
so this actually explains how you've
rescued these two
hostages is that it um
well no there were two other people
there
these guys were in the hole
well um the problem is all the gossip
magazines and the newspapers have
different details about your rescue will
you set the record straight and tell our
audiences how exactly you rescued these
poor hostages stuck in their hole from
their capitals
um i don't think they were watching them
going and that's why they're feeling
whole
uh and they covered in a lot of dirt so
at first they kind of looked like you
know they could have been sort of um
some sort of an archaeological thing
see
but we heard from our super secret
insider that these two people are
actually kidnapped
oh by aliens yes
it happens to me all the time it's just
walking home one day and
my girlfriend
another perspective here can you tell us
how you managed to get kidnapped in the
first place in that hole
well
i'm so scared
there was a big group of people
and
victims you have known each other from
possibly past lives
well i didn't recognize them at first
because of the dirt
yes i was an ancient egyptian pharaoh
and
well my sources say that it was actually
james roose pre-medical high school
was that i thought it was pretty law
on the other hand
i was just looking i'm just noticing
that before but you've got this awful
awful injury oh god yes that's why i've
been holding my knees all the time
was actually responsible for your
injury then a past life
as a slave
i often had to have to kneel like this
you see
after after decades of you know i
wouldn't beat him
it now carries on with me from every
past life
kept us alive i mean i was in such a
panic but you taught me the most amazing
calming down
tell us tell us please exactly
what these three s's are
wonder woman please tell us what the
threes are and you may demonstrate in
any way you would like
honor and water
the first one
is soil
shops
s for your calming down process um
oh science
sorry and what does science do to calm
you down
please does she get to burn things
you know and they also help to emit dirt
they would never be able to go home
without it
it really was crazy
it was very good so ladies and gentlemen
now you know it is
soil
well
that was absolutely not smacking amazing
but uh we all know that being a
superhero isn't all about saving
good people and beating up on nausea
villains indeed every superhero has to
confront his or her worst darkest fears
that's right wonderweb
we have
your parents
i cannot believe it i can't believe it
you don't want to do medicine
okay
you want to go to tafe
fine
but
you want to do
maths
to me
that's right
as
sorry
technical issues ladies gentlemen
you have to start by digging holes lots
and lots of them
so that people fall in them and then
you're resting them
um
i do remember that you were in
hand-to-hand combat without captor i
mean you knocked him down in five super
special martial arts moves
i think the first one was called angry
birds but i forgot the rest
such interesting moves i'm not even
hurdle
you know what this means guys
it's instant replay time
every week we get our hero here to
reenact his or her most heroic moment
so
please
act out your five-step process to saving
today starting with angry birds
no you're actually demonstrating with
eduardo over there
angry birds
like
oh
i've also heard that the second move is
called candy crush now could you please
elaborate what is candy crush
right
that is absolutely amazing don't you
agree that was amazing
bee baller
and how does that help you knock down
the captain
well
that's
that makes a lot of sense
now our final your best secret move that
will defeat all enemies
what is it wonder woman
it's a favorite of mine and many of you
out there
it was nice to know that
we had a we have a superhero here ready
to defend jack's ruse even though she's
kind of a pyromaniac and a little slave
driver
i also noticed how
the first opportunity he had he made
that's a slave
so
it's a it's a factory rivalry really
getting up there
no no
i don't feel this part really did
justice to my acting abilities so i'm
just gonna let english like this one oh
so being a better man
that's good well i think i think it's
safe to say that the school would agree
with me saying that you both did quite a
good job so i'm gonna announce both of
you the winner all right so
will this affect my english mark
anyway james just give a round of
applause
you